ça peut passer de
natacha et patrice savard ont été
surpris par les variations de prix entre
les billets de l'omnium banque nationale
prenons ces deux sièges du court central
pour la séance de jeudi midi il coûte
544 $ tandis que les deux mêmes places
pour les parties du vendredi à la même
heure se vendent à 790 $ en quarts de
finale et ils peuvent encore augmenter
dans les prochaines heures c'est ce
qu'on appelle des prix dynamique pour
nos suivi leur ce qui se fait ailleurs
en fait dans dans la plupart des grands
spectacles sportifs et un algorithme qui
calcule avec le nombre de billets reste
à
savoir jusqu'à un maximum comme les
billets d'avion les prix des places au
tournoi de tennis à montréal augmente
selon l'offre et la demande sur une même
rangé les spectateurs peuvent payer
leurs billets à des prix très variés
vous pourrez découvrir une clientèle
voyant les prix de dernière minute
stéphane langlois préfère amener ses
enfants aux parties de tennis plus
abordable sur les terrains secondaires
et il n'est pas le seul
canadien
on entre le coup rogers parce que c'est
sûr qu'elle court central je trouvais ça
vraiment cher pour des places quitté
très très haut là le directeur des
internationaux du canada défend la
stratégie de vente de billets à des prix
dynamique c'est bon pour nous c'est bon
pour le développement du sport parce
qu'on veut mais tous les profits de
l'omnium banque nationale pour le
développement du tennis et des jeunes
les prix fixe pour les événements
sportifs seront de moins en moins la
norme si certains sont mécontents
beaucoup d'autres acceptent cette
nouvelle réalité à preuve la partie avec
félix roger alias m affiche complet et
si charles du boullay radio canada
montréal